[Music]
this is a build I've been using on and
off for a long time and it has only had
minor tweaks over the years there won't
be anything new here for the more
seasoned player but I'm going to go out
there and say that this is and has
always been the easiest build to play
heroic and legendary content with
admittedly it can be a little boring and
it certainly isn't as fast as a lot of
other builds but if you're feeling a
little lazy and you're just looking to
farm heroics with full directives and
not having to put too much effort in
this is exactly what you need to be
running also the beauty of this build is
that even with terrible roles
unoptimized stats and God or flame it
will still get the job done albeit a
little slower anyway in the interest of
keeping this video short and sweet let's
jump into it
the idea behind this build is all about
leading your skills do all the work for
you with just a little bit of input from
you to proc certain talents the
automated drone and turret are more than
capable of handling even the most
difficult enemy while you sit
comfortably back behind cover far from
the fight
here I am running two pieces of empress
International on the mask and gloves for
the brexit bonus of plus 10 skill health
and plus 10 skill damage
two pieces of honey you corporation on
the backpack and knee pads for the brand
zip bonus of plus 10 skill haste and
plus 10 skill damage
the backpack is the named honey you
force multiplier
the chest is women wear with the kinetic
momentum talent and gives the brand set
bonus of plus 10 skill damage
I'm sure you're starting to see a trend
here for the holster I am running the
waveform Exotic
all but one piece has been rolled into
plus one skill tier the last one has
been rolled into armor and that will
make more sense soon the secondary
attributes have been rolled into skill
damage first and then skill haste
if you have school haste for all of your
gear mods you should be sitting with
more than 125 skill haste overall but if
you can't get this High don't worry too
much this is actually much higher than
you need
the primary weapon I'm using is the
capacitor exotic but don't worry if you
don't have one of these this isn't
completely necessary while its Talent
adds a truckload of damage to your
skills output and weapon the named rifle
called Harmony is still a very solid
substitute
the specialization is technician this
will provide plus 10 skill damage plus
12 damage to drones and Robotics but
will also Grant an extra skill tier and
as you can only be a Max of skill tier 6
this is why one of my gear pieces has
its core attribute rolled into armor
to be honest one piece into armor
doesn't really give a hell of a lot more
resistance in the higher difficulties
maybe like half a bullet but at least
the stat isn't being wasted
if you hadn't figured it out by now the
skills I'm using are Striker drone and
assault parrot if you are feeling
maximum lazy these will hurt for 110 to
120k and 170 to 190k
but if you're feeling only moderately
lazy and don't mind getting off your ass
to fire a few rounds into the hostels
they should hit for 170 to 185k and 220
to 300K
and with the 125 skill haste you'll be
able to pop these out every 10 to 11
seconds
also no shame in the maximum lazy option
this is why we're running this build
right
and that's pretty much it
the playstyle for this build is fairly
simple but also reasonably forgiving if
you really just can't be asked pop out
your drone take some cover pop out your
turret
make sure to Target them onto the
enemies that are hushing your lazy buzz
like rushes or grenadiers and if you
feel like putting in a small amount of
effort spray some rounds in the general
direction so your robot slaves can do
more damage
the only thing I would mention about
this build is don't use it in countdown
unless you really want to piss off all
of your teammates
your super strong drone is a pain in the
ass when it gets hijacked at the
extraction point
otherwise thank you very much for
watching and I'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Music]
thank you